[Música]
es el 27 de mayo de 1974 día en el que
valery giscard stein se convirtió en el
tercer presidente de la quinta república
francesa
[Música]
para esta campaña electoralmente lo que
ustedes han votado por el cambio el
cambio político económico y social y
también eso es fiable decepcionar ánimos
y mantuvo su promesa y rápidamente se
dedicó a modernizar a la sociedad
francesa sus reformas más memorables
fueron llevadas a cabo durante los
primeros dos años de la presidencia como
disminuir la edad de votación desde los
21 años hasta los 18 también marcó hitos
para las mujeres permitiendo el divorcio
por mutuo acuerdo y creando un nuevo
ministerio dedicado a los derechos de la
mujer sólo meses después de llegar al
cargo su ministra de salud sin un pib
impulsó la legalización del aborto
a nivel internacional que es que puso la
integración europea en el corazón de su
agenda haciendo de la alianza entre
alemania y francia- la fuerza motora de
lo que se convertiría en la unión
europea junto con el canciller alemán
helmut schmidt encabezó la creación del
consejo europeo y poco después de que la
crisis del petróleo de 1973 detuviera la
economía mundial fueron sus esfuerzos
los que llevaron a la primera reunión
del grupo de economías avanzadas del g7
y
vamos a abordar cuestiones que afectan
al comercio y las finanzas
internacionales la ciudad
bajo el mandato de giscard d'estaing map
francia mantuvo su interés en los
asuntos africanos dijo ser un campeón
del continente y dijo a áfrica en el
centro de su agenda de política exterior
convirtiéndose en el primer jefe de
estado francés en visitar argelia
después de su independencia su decisión
de intervenir en zaire en 1978
finalmente eclipsaría todo lo que hizo
en áfrica cuando los rebeldes
respaldados por angola y cuba invadieron
la ciudad de colores y rescates stein
envió tropas francesas para recuperarla
pero los críticos lo acusaron de usar su
cargo para cultivar amistades cercanas
con jefes de estado
y es que antes de por casa
ha grabado listo a dedo
en 1979 pagó el precio de acercarse
demasiado a la formación del presidente
de la república centroafricana jumping
del bocazas fiscal fue acusado de
aceptar un regalo de diamantes de bocas
a una acusación que rechazó pero que
empañó su presidencia
el folies de sus actos clandestinos
deben dejarse morir por sí mismo
esfuerzo
defensor acérrimo de la integración
europea se dedicó posteriormente a
consolidar las instituciones de la unión
europea en 2001 presidió la convención
sobre el futuro de europa
el yogur solo
en el umbral de una nueva era
caminaremos juntos hacia una nueva
europa de la nube lo esperaba sellar su
legado como el arquitecto de la
construcción europea pero en 2005 los
franceses rechazaron el plan en un
referéndum a pesar de eso
valéry giscard stein nunca dejó de
tratar de ganarse a los euroescépticos y
se mantuvo fuera de los titulares hasta
que una periodista alemana lo acusó de
tocarla inapropiadamente al finalizar
una entrevista en 2018 en mayo de este
año las autoridades abrieron una
investigación al respecto